Yeah. Okay. So Hannah Rand,
she is a philosopher that not a lot of people know about,
but she's a Jewish woman during the Holocaust.
And she was intern intern at Bergen Belsen, which was,
uh, basically Auschwitz for women. And she escaped,
she came to the United States and she had worked with Heidecker,
even though he's supposed to be antisemitic and Nazi and everything,
but they were lovers. Okay.
So she comes out and she she's at Columbia university and she teaches philosophy
there. And, um, she writes this, she writes two books, which I'll recommend.
One is called Eichmann in Jerusalem, where she attended,
attends the Nuremberg trials.
And she basically makes this really a Stu observation about evil. And she says,
I come in is one of the people who sent the Jews to the concentration camps who
ran the trains. Okay. Um, and she said,
the thing about Eichmann was that he didn't seem particularly evil.
Actually. He seemed to be quite a nice guy. She said,
what was interesting about him was he seemed incredibly thoughtless and stupid.
And she said, and use a lot of stereotypes like memes.
So she actually wrote about memes before we had them.
And now people just use memes and they're actually used against us,
even there's even a segments of warfare called memetic warfare.
Alright. So memes are something that can sway a whole population of people. Um,
so she wrote about memes before they were even in existence and that's Eichmann
in Jerusalem.
And I think she also has some really amazing things to say about evil is that,
um, when people remained thoughtless,
she has another book called the life of the mind, which is gigantic.
And I don't think anybody will read it, but frankly,
it's one of the best books I've ever read.
And I've read it many times and basically the life of the mind and the life of
the mind, she asks a very simple question. She says,
why do people do bad things? Why are they evil? And what she says,
she wonders if it's,
she says that bad people sleep well at night contrary to,
you know how the saying, how do you sleep at night? Well,
that's only because you're a good person that you're asking that question
because you actually have a conscience and a conscience is this dual kind of,
you fight with yourself about the consequences of your actions. And she says,
bad people don't seem to have a conscience.
So they actually sleep well at night.
And so she goes through the whole history of philosophy, uh, about evil.
And that's really a good one too, but I have, um,
also have to recommend this one too. There's one more.
So I know I recommended two, but just from the same philosopher, uh,
my friend Jeffrey Kripal, he's at rice university and he's in my fields. Right?
Uh, religious studies, he wrote, he's written several books. I mean,
he's written a heck of a lot of books. Let's put it that way, but he's, um, his,
I think his best book or the one that impacted me the most is called the authors
of the impossible.
And his book is his writing is very much like niches writing in the sense that
he it's almost as if he reaches out of the pages and he grabs you and it kind of
slaps you around and says about this, you know, and you can't help,
but be changed after you've read it.
And he's got a great chapter in there about jock valet.
Oh.
So he called us a bunch of different thinkers and authors that are out that
somehow are, what is it?
Renegade in some aspect to revolutionary.
Yeah. They're thinking the impossible. Right? There's a great one.
He's written called mutants and mystics. Ray talks about, uh,
the comic strips. Uh, the, um, gosh,
why can't I remember the name of the person he just died. Stan Lee.
He talks about the history of the comics by Stan Lee and they're all paranormal.
They all start off super paranormal. And it's fascinating.
Um, on, on the topic of Ana, uh, rent.
Uh, so I haven't read her work,
but I've vaguely touched upon sort of like commentary of
her work.
And it seems like some people think her work is dangerous in some aspect.
I don't know if you can comment on why that is. I just,
it feels like similar with iron Rand or something like that, where like,
this is a, I should say not dangerous, but controversy.
Yes it is. Yeah. They think it's controversial. Um,
this is the reason I believe, um, I've heard of the controversy.
The controversy is that she didn't, I, she, first of all, um,
she is Jewish and she did escape a concentration camp,
and yet she's called, she's been called anti-Jewish.
And I think part of that was that she basically was saying something
that I believe that a lot of normal people are like
Eichmann and evil things are done by people who just follow the
rules and they don't think about what they're doing.
And that's one of the most pernicious forms of evil of our
time.